erster erfolg gegen die korona epidemie
die einschränkungen in deutschland
wirken das robert-koch-institut sagt
aber auch wir dürfen jetzt nicht
nachlassen
am ausgangspunkt der krise zdf china
korrespondent ulf röller ist ingo hahn
wo es immer noch strenge kontrollen gibt
und ablenkung im autokino die neue liebe
zu einem alten bekannten
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers die welt an diesem
freitag guten abend hinein schön dass
sie dabei sind
wir beginnen mit den aktuellen zahlen
zur epidemie in deutschland wie
entwickeln sich die infektionen wie sehr
steigt die zahl der toten
es sind die daten die letztlich über die
große frage entscheiden ob und wann die
enormen einschränkungen unseres lebens
gelockert werden
es gibt heute eine vorsichtige positive
tendenz zu melden bei der eindämmung der
pandemie in deutschland aber es ist eine
entwicklung die eingeordnet werden muss
das macht jetzt thomas konsum stand
heute 18 uhr 30 meldet die johns hopkins
universität mehr als 89.000 durch tests
bestätigte infektionen und 1200 und acht
todesfälle in verbindung mit cupid 19
zunehmende zahlen aber kein grund für
zunehmende besorgnis findet die
bundesregierung einen ersten trend in
den letzten tagen gesehen haben der zahl
der neuinfektionen maßnahmen gegen
krohne kontrollen etwa wirken sagt auch
das robert koch institut das zeige sich
zum beispiel so in den vergangenen
wochen steckte jeder infizierte fünf
weitere menschen an
seit einigen tagen nur noch einen noch
zu viel denn erst wenn diese zahl unter
1 gedrückt wird
dann lässt die epidemie langsam nach das
ist unser ziel
weiteres ziel die entwicklung
verlangsamen damit nicht viele kranke
gleichzeitig beatmungsmaschine brauchen
vor einer woche verdoppelte sich die
zahl der erkrankten schon alle 4,8 tage
jetzt erst alle neun tage
die bundesregierung will nun eine noch
stärkere bremse möglichst 14 tage soll
es dauern
fortschritte gibt es also sagen die
experten man dürfe aber nicht nachlassen
im kampf gegen korona das ist eine
entwicklung die natürlich auch die
bundesregierung genau verfolgt die
bundeskanzlerin hat sich heute nach der
quarantäne zu hause zurück im kanzleramt
gemeldet mit einem neuen appell an alle
bürger und noch eines und bitte nehmen
sie auch das
auch kurz reisen innerhalb deutschlands
an die see oder in die berge oder zu
verwandten kann es dieses jahr über
ostern nicht geben
das sind harte wahrheiten ich weiß wir
sind gewöhnt und zu bewegen etwas zu
unternehmen zu reisen wenn wir wollen
und wohin wir wollen
diese persönliche entfaltung ist ein
grundzug unseres freien lebens und setzt
sind da plötzlich überall regeln
einschränkungen verbote aber sie sind
buchstäblich lebenswichtig sagt
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
testen testen testen und zwar am besten
indem man antikörper im blut bestimmt
und das am besten flächen deckend damit
klar wird wie die ansteckung läuft und
wie verbreitet sie wirklich ist so sieht
zusammengefasst eine strategie aus im
kampf gegen das virus die jetzt an
vielen orten in deutschland umgesetzt
werden soll stephanie heim berichtet auf
diesem verfahren der blutuntersuchung
ruhen große hoffnungen
seit anfang der woche beginnen labore
wie hier in geesthacht damit in
blutproben nach antikörpern auf das
neuartige corona virus zu suchen
hier geht es nicht um diese akute phase
wenn akute symptome auftreten sondern
wenn sich der körper das immunsystem
eben mit dem virus auseinandergesetzt
hat dann werden wir irgendeine gebildet
die sich gegen das virus richten und das
immunsystem aktivieren
wie viele menschen tatsächlich schon mit
dem virus in kontakt waren ist unklar
stichwort dunkelziffer doch auch wer
womöglich überhaupt keine
krankheitssymptome hatte würde etwa zwei
wochen nach virus kontakt antikörper
bilden
wir können das virus erst seit drei
monaten
und was man aber weiß es bei den anderen
coronaviren dass sie eine immunität
induzieren und dass die ungefähr ein bis
zwei jahre anhält aber wie lange das für
dieses neue virus der fall ist das
wissen wir noch nicht
doch nur antikörper tests geben auskunft
wie viele menschen womöglich immun sind
so der lka präsident im einzelfall kann
das entscheidend sein natürlich kann man
bestimmte person wenn sie denn einen
antikörper titer haben kann man sich zum
beispiel überlegen dass sie vielleicht
für bestimmte arbeiten wieder eingesetzt
werden oder er eingesetzt werden als als
andere personen in den nächsten wochen
vielleicht schon nach ostern sollen
antikörper tests in den laboren in
größerer stückzahl verfügbar sein
dann können ärzte das blut ihrer
patienten testen lassen
wir kommen gleich noch mal nach
deutschland zurück erst nach italien
das land hat unfassbar schwierige wochen
hinter sich und hofft dass das aller
schlimmste vorüber ist der chef des
zivilschutzes sid italien jetzt an einem
entscheidenden punkt es gibt aber auch
in den letzten 24 stunden wieder
hunderte tote und immer mehr menschen
die in not geraten aus rom andreas
postel geben und nehmen in der not in
neapel wo mit jedem tag der korona käse
die bedürftigkeit steigt setzt die
fiktion ist ein ganz einfaches zeichen
der solidarität wer hat der spendet
lebensmittel in einen korb oben wird
gekocht und die mahlzeit kommt dann
herunter verdient der hunger hat auf den
notfall durch das virus folgt jetzt ein
sozialer notfall
es ist die größte prüfung italien seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg das krematorium in
mailand musste wegen überlastung
zeitweise schließen zu viele särge
warten auf die einäscherung und jeden
abend um 18 uhr gibt es die neuesten
zahlen der italienischen katastrophe vom
zivilschutz in rom
wir stehen hier vor der zentrale des
zivilschutzes italiens von hier aus
führt die korona krise des landes
gemanagt und das ist angelo bonelli
der oberste zivilschützer sagt es gebe
signale der hoffnung es wird an der
anzahl der infektionen erkannt wie
abnehmen sind vor allem gibt es keinen
exponentiellen anstieg mehr wie zu
beginn als die maßnahmen noch nicht zu
streng waren
auch auf zeichen europäischer
solidarität hatte italien lange warten
müssen viel wasser auf die mühlen der
europa gegner vielleicht zuviel
staatspräsident materieller jedenfalls
mit einem eindringlichen appell
ich wünsche mir dass alle die schwere
der bedrohung für europa vollständig
verstehen bevor es zu spät ist
italien braucht kraftvolle zeichen aus
europa sowie im kleinen dieser tage in
neapel die panade solidar die körbe der
solidarität die kommissionspräsidenten
der eu ursula von der leyen sieht
zeichen einer wachsenden solidarität
unter den mitgliedsstaaten das habe sich
bei der schnellen einigung auf ein
europäisches kurzarbeitergeld gezeigt
alle seien an gemeinsamen lösungen
interessiert sagte von der leyen vor
wenigen minuten hier im zdf und das
ganze gespräch gleich nach uns in einem
zdf spezial was nun frau von der leyen
die kommissionspräsidentin im gespräch
mit bettina schausten und peter frey
kein land der welt ist so stark von
corona virus betroffen wie die usa vor
allem in den großen städten steigt die
zahl der infizierten zusätzliches
problem
etwa 35 millionen amerikaner haben keine
krankenversicherung viele davon können
sich die behandlung im krankenhaus
einfach nicht leisten
die regierung will jetzt einspringen wie
ines trams berichtet lea ist es im
deutschen bio restaurant in washington
dc super papa musste seine drei
restaurants dichtmachen auf ein darlehen
aus dem corona hilfspaket hofft er doch
66 mitarbeiter hat er bereits entlassen
auch trainer maik ihre
krankenversicherung zahlen zu der bis
ende april
dann ist auch die weg es war
herzzerreißend für mich ihn und die
anderen zu entlassen nicht helfen zu
können es bewegt mich immer noch
insgesamt zehn millionen amerikaner
haben sich bereits im zuge der korona
krise arbeitslos gemeldet ein hilfspaket
von über zwei billionen dollar soll
helfen auch verspricht die regierung
einzuspringen für die rund 35 millionen
menschen ohne krankenversicherung
der präsident hat unsere arbeitsgruppe
angewiesen einen weg zu finden dass eine
behandlung für diese menschen bezahlt
wird
völlig unklar derzeit ob diese zusage
umzusetzen ist unklar auch wie schnell
die gelder aus dem hilfspaket zu den
menschen kommen sicher ist die usa
erwarten eine soziale krise nach der
gesundheitskrise usa sind mit ihrem
dünnen gesponnenen netz an sozialer
sicherheit und den schlecht
aufgestellten institutionen nicht
vorbereitet auf eine plötzliche notlage
dieser größenordnung im deutschen bier
haus in washington haben sie die würste
eingefroren
die hoffnung ist dass sie sie bald
wieder aufbauen können
china hat für samstag einen nationalen
trauertag ausgerufen im gedenken an die
opfer der korona epidemie soll das land
drei minuten lang stillstehen
aufhorchen lässt eine nachricht aus haan
der stadt von der die pandemie ausging
hohe funktionäre haben die einwohner der
elf-millionen-metropole jetzt
aufgefordert ihre schutzmaßnahmen zu
verstärken und so weit wie möglich in
ihren wohnungen zu bleiben
unser china korrespondent ulf röller ist
live im u-bahnhof guten abend was ist da
los kehrt jetzt das virus etwa wieder
zurück das ist die große sorge hier in
woran aber auch wirklich die große sorge
im ganzen land in china dass es eine
zweite infektionswelle gibt aber china
muss jetzt den wirtschaftsmotor
anschmeißen und muss deshalb war sie
bewegung im land zu lassen und mit
dieser bewegung entsteht die gefahr dass
das virus sich auch bewegt und mitreißt
und das zweite große problem was
mittlerweile in china diskutiert wird
ist dass ganz viele keine symptome
zeigen obwohl sie infiziert sind und das
heißt dass wahrscheinlich die
dunkelziffer der infiziert wesentlich
höher ist und das macht eben groß
so große sorgen hier und du bist live in
johann wie hat man sich das leben dort
im moment vorzustellen
als wir sind vor wenigen stunden
angekommen und das ist schon eine sehr
bizarre atmosphäre
wir sind ihr die stadt rein gefahren da
sind dann diese doch sehr sehr hohen
hochhäuser und die sind heller leuchtet
und da steht dann wache wo hartmut halte
durch und gleichzeitig fährt man dann
durch diese lehren straßenschluchten
quasi eine geister hat man hat
geisterhafte atmosphäre sind keine
menschen auf der straße
man spürt diese angst hat der stadt und
man spürt dass vor allem auch wenn man
ein reist wir sind mit dem zug von
peking nach vorangekommen
und wenn man dort ankommt wird man
sofort empfangen und dann wird erst wird
man erst mal ab gesprüht und
desinfiziert und wenn das passiert ist
muss man zu einem sogenannten
sicherheits check muss ein pass vorlegen
und sein handy vorlegen und dann wird
ein bewegungsprofil erstellt in unserem
fall haben sie festgestellt dass wir 14
tage peking nicht verlassen haben dass
es gut weil sie hatten angst dass wir
aus deutschland kam
dann hätten sie uns nicht reingelassen
weil die chinesen ganz klar seiten das
virus kommt jetzt vom ausland also bei
all diesen maßnahmen merkt man wie hoch
die angst ist und wie groß die
anspannung ist info an
herzlichen dank für diese eindrücke
heute abend die virus krise wird auch
immer mehr zur autokrise weltweit und in
deutschland brechen die verkaufszahlen
drastisch ein
die konzerne müssen die produktion
einstellen und viele tausend mitarbeiter
erstmal nach hause schicken
und keiner weiß wie lange das dauern
wird
fest steht die autobranche leidet massiv
unter der pandemie alle details jetzt
von peter böhme und lothar becker beim
autohaus dts in koblenz geht momentan
wenig beim neuwagenverkauf eigentlich
gar nichts die korona krise schlägt voll
durch
also bei uns ist der komplett zum
erliegen gekommen also seid ja man kann
sagen seit mitte märz
de facto null davor war zumindest noch
die nachfrage darum das 1 3
auch verkauft aber seitdem bei uns
wirklich nur die werkstatt hält seinem
betrieb mit acht mitarbeitern noch am
laufen und in der branche sieht es nicht
anders aus alarmstimmung
der verband der automobilindustrie gab
heute bekannt dass die neuzulassungen im
märz im vergleich zum februar um 38
prozent eingebrochen sind
wir erleben in der tat den drastischen
einbruch gegen die automobilindustrie in
der tat zu verzeichnen hatte im in- und
im ausland die werke stehen still
die händler und lieferketten sind zum
erliegen gekommen und die absätze
natürlich damit auch wir stehen vor
großen herausforderungen
wie groß weiß derzeit niemand der
autoanalyst christoph stürmer rechnet
mit einer mehr als roten bilanz auf dem
markt unser basisszenario geht im moment
von etwa 10 bis 15 prozent verlusten aus
bei nur vier wochen schließung wenn es
sechs wochen werden dann könnten wir
auch bis zu 30 prozent des
fahrzeugabsatzes verlieren in den
automaten wie hier heute in düsseldorf
gab es noch betrieb die werkstätten sind
ja weiterhin geöffnet und die showrooms
auch aber kaufen kann man nur noch
telefonisch oder online und hat dann ein
weiteres problem mit der anmeldung des
schönen neuen wagens denn immer mehr
zulassungsstellen sind wegen corona
ebenfalls geschlossen
die korona krise durchkreuzt auch die
pläne von studenten dazu heute dass das
sommersemester soll an deutschen
hochschulen wie geplant stattfinden und
am 20 april beginnen
darauf haben sich die bundesländer
verständigt lehrveranstaltungen sollen
erst mal vor allem digital angeboten
werden
in der krise zeigt sich wozu menschen
fähig sind im positiven und dem
negativen in frankreich berichten gerade
die die in den krankenhäusern arbeiten
also die auf die es besonders ankommt
über rührende hilfsaktionen aber eben
auch man kann es kaum glauben von
anfeindungen aus paris christel haas
schwer bewaffnet schützen sie eine
lieferung von atemschutzmasken
immer öfter wird die fracht unterwegs
gestohlen masken sind ein rares gut
genauso wie desinfektionsmittel das auto
dieser krankenschwester wurde
aufgebrochen um an die begehrten
utensilien zu gelangen
das wenige was wir haben würden wir
gerne behalten um kranken zu helfen
viel härter als die diebstähle trifft
die helfer aber ein anderes phänomen
anonyme beschwerde briefe geschrieben
aus angst vor ansteckung busse wäre es
möglich für unsere sicherheit dass sie
die türen unseres wohnhauses nicht mehr
berühren oder vielleicht versuchen
zeitweise woanders zu wohnen
sie treten das ist ja schön dass man uns
abends applaudiert aber dann findet man
solche bösartigen worte im postkasten
das kann ich nicht verstehen kein
einzelfall immer wieder tauchen solche
briefe auf hier sehen sie immer draußen
mit ihrem hund ist das
verantwortungsvoll wo sie doch direkten
kontakt zu infizierten haben
die polizei hat jetzt aufgerufen solche
fälle zu melden und droht mit hohen
strafen
die anfeindungen werden sehr ernsten
professionelleren pflegepersonal und die
sicherheitskräfte erleben derzeit immer
mehr anfeindungen und einschüchterungen
das ist inakzeptabel dass diese menschen
zusätzlich psychologisch belastet werden
die große mehrheit der franzosen aber
zeigt große solidarität manche
restaurants haben extra ihre küche
geöffnet für ein kostenloses essen das
mit den worten geliefert wird ihr seid
helden
für mehr informationen zucker oder krise
empfehlen wir ihnen die zdf- heute- app
dort finden sie einen live blog und
berichte über die lage in weiteren
ländern rund um die welt und jetzt
erinnern wir an einen großen soul
musiker bill withers ist gestorben mit
81 jahren
aber drei lieder x-mal gecovert haben
ihn unsterblich gemacht lovely day und
natürlich diese beiden hier
si
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit viel wie noch nie
jetzt noch eine meldung vom fußball
hansi flick bleibt cheftrainer beim fc
bayern münchen man sei zufrieden mit
seiner arbeit deshalb wird der vertrag
bis zum sommer 2003 und 20 verlängert
und jetzt ein bemerkenswertes comeback
alle veranstaltungen abgesagt kinos
geschlossen manche filmfans in
deutschland entdecken da einen klassiker
wieder das autokino
ursprünglich kam das aus den usa haben
dort waren autokinos in den 1950 er
jahren der letzte schrei cabrios
cadillacs und shavies drängten sich vor
den leinwänden dieser ort bringt die
menschen jetzt auch bei uns wieder neu
zusammen geschützt in ihren autos
carsten edinger endlich mal wieder
ausgehen wenn auch das eigene auto mit
muss die besucher im autokino in essen
sind froh über die gelungene abwechslung
in coruna alltag
für uns ist es tatsächlich als familie
auch das allererste mal dass wir es
überhaupt zusammen machen also eine
tolle neue erfahrung trotz dieser lage
einen kinofilm schauen abschalten abends
man nicht zu hause sein
das autokino in essen ist eines der
wenigen in deutschland das noch geöffnet
hat die betreiber konnten die stadt
davon überzeugen dass sie hier alle
sicherheitsvorkehrungen einhalten
gescannt werden die tickets durch die
geschlossene scheibe bloß keinen kontakt
zu den kunden die autos sollen nach
möglichkeit nicht verlassen werden
obwohl manche müssen doch noch schnell
plätze tauschen kinder nach vorne eltern
nach hinten ausnahmsweise das autokino
eigentlich ein relikt aus vergangener
zeit erfährt momentan ungeahnte
aufmerksamkeit viele haben eine neue
kino liebe für sich entdeckt ich als zu
hart sind nicht mehr alles und ich sagt
nach zwei wochen und ist in zwei monaten
dann gibt es endlich in versprochenen
film in essen heißt das für ein paar
stunden abschalten und die probleme der
welt um sich herum vergessen
die deutschen versuchen sich die zeit zu
versüßen im wahrsten sinne des wortes
übrigens osterartikel laufen zwar
äußerst schleppend aber alles andere
boomt der süßwaren handelsverband
spricht von einem zweistelligen plus
wenn schon zu hause bleiben dann
wenigstens mit schokolade beim wetter
kommt die sonne mehr gleich von gunther
tiersch so und das waren die nachrichten
in 20 minuten
ich danke für ihr großes interesse
marietta slomka macht das heute journal
um 22 uhr 20 bis morgen und von uns
allen hier wo immer das geht ihnen einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
dann bliebe zuschauer in den nächsten
tagen wird es bei uns richtig war das
ist ja nicht so ganz einfach wenn man zu
hause bleiben soll
die kaltluft ist aber passé
vorübergehend morgen nochmal aus dem
nordwesten kommt sie aber dieses hoch
bringt die wetteränderung es zieht unter
verstärkung nach polen und dann kann
eben aus dem südwesten die warmluft
kommen und es wird auch bei uns immer
sonniger heute nacht haben noch starke
bewölkung in der mitte deutschlands ab
und zu kann es noch ein bisschen regnen
aber meist klappt es ja auf und dann
wird es noch mal richtig frostig in
deutschland bis zu minus zwei oder sogar
minus drei grad tagsüber bleibt es dann
im nordosten noch ziemlich frisch da
sind es noch neun bis elf grad sonst 12
bis 14 und am rhein entlang auch bis zu
17 grad es wird dort auch überwiegend
sonnig sein sonst haben wir im osten
noch von brandenburg bis bayern noch die
starke bewölkung und auch in schleswig
holstein gibt es vielleicht noch mal
einen kleinen regenschauer war dem
schwachen wind aber dann ist er sonntag
damit sonne und wärme und so geht es in
der nächsten woche weiter sonnig warm
und eben auch trocken
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut